septembre 1975 pour la première fois en
france un parti organise des universités
d'été une initiative des jeunes
giscardiens à montpellier 1re classe
politique pour ses 400 jeunes réunis à
l'initiative d'henri giscard d'estaing
le fils aîné du président de la
république le concept vient tout droit
des états-unis table ronde entre
militants et responsables du parti
discussions sur le programme mais aussi
et surtout des ateliers pour devenir un
miltant digne de ce nom exemple avec ce
cours d'élocution donné par jean pierre
soisson alors secrétaire d'état vous
employer le langage des français et la
vie de tous les jours et ça c'est très
important si vous voulez vous compris il
faut convaincre et parler un langage
très sage cette première est un succès
et elle est renouvelée l'année suivante
avec 1000 jeunes giscardiens toujours la
même recette discussions échanges et
surtout formation projet de loi est un
point important on apprend aussi à con
côté des affiches rédiger des
communiqués à la presse alors en 1977 le
parti socialiste organise à son tour ces
stages de militants à la fin de l'été
concurrencer ses adversaires politiques
sur leur propre terrain il faut bien sûr
apprendre à faire des affiches ici à
oullins dans la banlieue de lyon les
étudiants du parti socialiste se risque
à la sérigraphie tout comme les jeunes
giscardiens atelier affiches collages et
bien sûr discours public avec des
briefings de professionnels la position
c'est la position ce qui me faisais tu
là comme ça qu'ils fassent aujourd'hui
le très bien
[Musique]
les années passent et ses universités
d'été devienne le rendez-vous des
militants dans tous les partis des
stages de quelques jours et quelques
semaines un peu partout en france
l'ambiance est détendue en 1983 ce jeune
socialiste non vous venez pas d'avoir
croisé un ministre en toute simplicité
vous attendiez à voir facilement comme
ça des ministres temps des stages j'ai
été agréablement surpris et surtout du
contact facile quand pas vrai que nous
avons connu déchaîné sa profonde avis
shoah ministre de son plateau et aller
au centre avec nous ces stages de
militants étaient des initiatives
réservé aux jeunes souvent dépendantes
des fédérations locales mais en 1993 le
parti socialiste décide d'organiser un
rassemblement national entre tous les
militants et les membres du parti à la
fin de l'été la parole aux militants
pour peu qu'ils sachent se faire
entendre alors la vocation initiale des
universités d'été a bien changé place à
la communication politique les
universités d'été permettent aujourd'hui
de mesurer l'influencé d'un parti ou
encore de vérifier la popularité des
cadres
[Musique]